I was surprised that they make us they
make us fellas wear this is this makeup
they told me that I was too pale yeah
contrasted with with who you're going
out of your way to destroy yourself such
a lovely fellow and you're no it's true
I that's the one thing as you know
million years ago when I got started I
was thrown into it very quickly and the
one thing I didn't know and it's still
my least favorite part of the of the job
I love the job but they have to put so
much makeup on me because I'm a kind of
white that's hard to find in nature you
know so they're literally like they just
keep putting it on because TV lights are
very bright and you can't I wouldn't
show up you wouldn't see me I'm like the
kid from powder you know you just you
need to just so they fire hoses at me
filled with orange pumpkin spice for 20
minutes before I come out and meet meet
you though this is you with makeup yeah
I've got quite a bit of makeup yeah but
if you if you you know yeah I'll show
you my no I'll show you
that's my real
skintone and that's that's real skin
tone and then you put you know I think
they did I don't they don't even think
they did my hands cuz I just have I have
a lot of freckles on my hands I don't
know what happens they migrate away from
the face yes later in life because of
shame but they they have to put as much
on my hands cuz of the freckles the
freckles go let's get out of here the
freckles it's not a good it's a look I
hate it when I was a kid I had a lot of
fret dark freckles on my face yes and um
two front teeth that were dead that
didn't fall out and a orange hair that
was a book cut in a bowl by my mom who
decided there's six kids and she was
like there's no time hole haircuts for
everyone so I had a bowl haircut you
dead gray front teeth and then a lot of
freckles and I just hated the way I look
I just thought oh what a I just didn't
want
that's your origin story that's arguably
why you're so funny now in your one way
you're trying to be nice no it is I'm a
big believer as you are I oh I mean we
we talk all the time
and not really he calls but I don't take
I'm on another call what we have talked
about the comedian origin story no
because comedians are people that are
funny because it was all we had right
it's all I had as a kid
why was not my brothers and sisters were
better at things than I was and I didn't
know I was sort of in the middle of six
kids and I didn't and then you'd go to
school and he's a good athlete he's good
at this he's good at that and I didn't
know what I had and then one day I
discovered I had this I made some people
laugh and I said I must develop this and
only this well you're you're spinning
plates as fast as you can to draw
attention from the fact that I'm the
same way
couldn't do sports couldn't do math
couldn't do all these different things
and then you realize that the plate
spending itself is is kind of a thing
mm-hmm
yeah I I but I came to that slowly I
wait awake and I'm sorry was that good
did I do good tonight I'm the question
well hit me do good morning didn't
didn't me do good you were real good
yeah that's uh yes I I believe I'm
always trying to tell young people
interested in comedy like that yeah
there's a part that comes with it which
is you're hyper developing a defense
mechanism that you're doing my dad
looked at me once in the after watching
me you know do years of comedy and my
dad's a scientist and he looked at me
and he said I see what you're doing
you're making a living off something
that should probably be treated you said
that for real
you said that for real I understand and
I started to get mad and then realized
he's absolutely right I've taken my
dysfunction yes and I'm like and people
like ah money for you